okay it's time for hatred mail and it's
a very special day for hatred mail
because you will notice that the shirt I
am wearing today is the exact design
it's a reinterpreted design of today's
hatred mail banner which was originally
created by david pakman show viewer matt
Nahum I hope I'm pronouncing Matt's last
name correctly if you want this shirt
this is the only hatred mail shirt
available in the world I would venture
to say it's available as a perk as part
of our indiegogo fundraiser at david
pakman.com slash donate check it out but
that's enough of me talking let me
remind you what hatred mail is brace
yourselves for the only information that
can successfully penetrate a tinfoil hat
Patriot Man written by Patriots who hate
David Pakman because America and because
freedom my question about today's hatred
mail to you is does anybody understand
what the hell is being discussed in this
hatred mail this is the new world of
hate reott ISM under Donald Trump it is
getting far more depraved it is getting
far more difficult to understand let's
take a listen together David asks if you
want to be a gay just go openly nothing
to ashamed of a person whose soul
trapped inside the wrong body most of
your show is like it stink but funny
when you open your mouth
Trump fart coming out all through times
people wonder how that happens let's
throw out the illegal aliens I'll see
how you like the math I it seems as
though this Patriot is confused between
whether they're claiming I am gay or
claiming I am trans yeah that was put
together in a paragraph so you'd have to
imagine that the sentences have
something to do with one another
yeah I couldn't I couldn't make that out
it seemed like unrelated sentences sort
of strung together I'm actually sort of
scared Rachel to see how bad it gets
because you as you know the hatreds have
been out enforced for many many years
but since the election of
president-elect Donald Trump we have an
overflow
of hatred mail I can't I'm gonna have to
start doing two and three hatred males
per episode to even keep up with the
insanity they're hugely emboldened then
quite frankly I'm very scared right and
the free association nature of all this
has kind of increased tenfold since he's
been elected yeah I don't know what the
people are writing about I said what is
the subject of that I can tell somebody
doesn't like me right that's a that's I
can I can tell that that's very very
clear and they probably Harbor anti LGBT
beliefs but beyond that I couldn't sum
that up
I'm afraid that's just the abstract
version of a much longer essay about you
yeah what's the term we've used before
it's the equivalent of a a Rorschach
test something Rorschach there's some
funny phrase that at some point we came
up with but yeah it's basically like
paint splattered the it's an SAT
question paint splattered is too fine
art as hate reott mail is to writing
with logical spelling and grammar I
think that is the way that it would be
sort of like an SAT an allergy question
you remember you can turn hatred mail
into something positive by using coupon
code hey tree at forty to get a major
discount at david pakman.com slash
membership and if you want the hatred
mail shirt which i am modeling today it
is only available at david pakman.com
slash donate